social Clinton thanks so much for
joining us on Sky News today and let's
kick off with your visit to Belfast
we're here at Queen's University where
you're the chancellor
um I get the sense that Northern Ireland
and the peace process back in 1998 and
now 25 years on is very personal for you
am I right you are absolutely right I I
feel privileged to have been a witness
to history starting with my first visit
with my husband then the first sitting
president to come to Northern Ireland in
1995 all the way to today where the
leaders who helped to make the piece and
then implemented our you know not only
reflecting on what has happened but also
thinking about what needs to continue to
take place in order for Northern Ireland
to have the best possible future and on
that secretary Clinton your husband
called The Good Friday agreement a work
of genius and maybe it was when it came
to deliver in peace but do you accept
that it's failed to deliver good
government for the people of Northern
Ireland for nine of the 25 years since
the GFA was signed storm that's been
shut down do you think as Tony Blair has
said the agreement needs to quote amend
and adjust in order to make it work
better
well I do think it was a work of Genius
to end the conflict to create the
structure for uh self-governance within
the appropriate relationship uh with the
UK
and I think that it has worked
except when leaders decided it would no
longer work for their own reasons and
the question is whether leaders
themselves the current generation of
leaders can restore confidence in the
ability of the people of Northern
Ireland to elect a government that will
then actually govern or whether there
does as prime minister former prime
minister Blair said have to be some
adjustments within the agreement itself
I think the jury is out on that because
right now we're all hoping that they
will stand up the government now that
the Windsor agreement framework has been
adopted and get back to the business of
governing if they don't though I mean
the alliance party it's non-sectarian
it's the third largest in Northern
Ireland they want to move to a more
conventional Democratic model involving
simple majorities and coalitions of
parties do you agree with that concept
or is it wait and see well I I'm a
little bit wait and see because all of
these decisions should be made by the
people of Northern Ireland themselves I
do think that uh you know the alliance
party as you say which has now become
the third most quote popular party in
terms of the numbers elected for the
assembly has an important role to play
but the first order of business and I
would urge the UK government to make it
the first order is to get the government
going again it was stalled this time
around because of brexit I believe those
challenges have been met with this
agreement The Windsor agreement and
therefore the UK government in
particular should use its leverage to to
get the government going again here so
it's your message to the dummy
Democratic unions party get back to
storeman is that what you well I think
of them today I think it's very much in
their interest because as I understand
their position which
I believe was a reasonable position what
what is brexit going to mean you're
going to be installing borders that's
contrary to the Good Friday agreement
I I think that the deal that prime
minister sunac worked out with the EU
answers those questions and my argument
is not just to one political party but
to all of them if you look at the
privileged access Northern Ireland will
now have not just to the UK Market but
to trading partners of the UK and to the
EU Market that is almost the most
amazing opportunity that I can imagine
to become a magnet for business and
investment in the north which was also
the message from President Biden about
investment can I now turn to your
expertise as a former Secretary of State
and presidential candidate how worried
are you now about Ukraine there have
been warnings this week from within
Ukraine and the Pentagon leagues that
the country could lose control of the
Skies as they ran out of anti-aircraft
missiles is it time for the U.S and NATO
to provide those F-16 fighter jets to
repel Russian aggression I think that
U.S and NATO should do much more to
supply what Ukraine needs I was very
pleased that Poland and others have been
providing soviet-era Mig Jets I think we
ought to encourage NATO Nations
particularly those most directly
affected by this terrible Russian
aggression to provide more not only
planes to repel air space infractions
but also anti-aircraft missiles
Ukraine is getting enough help to be
able to withstand the Russian invasion
it needs to get enough help to repel the
Russian invasion are you worried that if
those F-16 fight struts are not provided
and additional equipment is not provided
that there is a risk Ukraine goes the
way of Syria where it's bombarded by the
Russians with no real protection does
that worry you well it worries me a lot
because Russia has proven that its
brutality knows no bounds what it did to
Syria it is doing to certain places
within Ukraine already and up until now
the ukrainians their own courage and and
their own intelligent uh use of the
resources they have in waging uh the
defense of their country has proven uh a
significant factor in preventing further
Russian advances and the Russians are
taking enormous losses I want to keep
the pressure up and make it even more on
the right Russians because as we now
look at the available information they
could get more brutal in terms of the
air defense Syria is a fair uh example
of what they're capable of doing that's
why they need their ukrainians need more
help to repel that okay and let's move
on to U.S politics next year America
goes to the polls Donald Trump is
running for president while under
criminal indictment this the man who
back in 2016 consistently Clues You of
law break in and actively encourage
chance of Lockhart directed at you it's
pretty ironic isn't it that he is now a
former president that could face a jail
term how does it make you feel well I
always thought about him and if you
follow him uh I think you can see it as
well he accuses people of doing things
he himself is doing it's a form of
psychological projection uh and I always
thought that uh his record in business
in particular but then as we saw him uh
in politics and government uh he was
someone who cared nothing about rules he
cared nothing about the law uh so he has
been indicted and there may be others as
well but he has said he's going to keep
running and there's nothing in our
current system of laws that would
prevent him from running but even if he
gets the Republican nomination he cannot
in my view be re-elected uh president
why can't he be re-elected because I
think people nomination I think people
are more people are on to him and his uh
Behavior than they were before he has a
hardcore of support that is likely to
help him win the Republican nomination
but in a general election against
President Biden I do not believe he can
win so you don't think he can win do you
think he's a bigger threat to Biden than
DeSantis
it's hard to tell I mean DeSantis is
unproven nobody really outside of
Florida knows very much about him and in
Florida they're watching him do crazy
things so I I actually believe that
President Biden will be re-elected
regardless of who the Republican nominee
is do you ever worry that President
Biden he will be in his 80s in a second
term isn't too old for the job I feel
like I could do the job I'm in you know
my mid 70s yeah well you could run in
2028 well I doubt that but I think uh it
really should be a matter of what he has
done as president and pulling together
um the transatlantic Alliance to support
Ukraine pulling together countries in
Asia to begin to stand up to uh Chinese
uh aggressiveness passing major
legislation through the Congress I think
he has a remarkable record and we're
living though Beth in a time when a lot
of people expect their leaders to be
performers
yes and so
is he a performer as we think of maybe
one of your prior Prime Ministers or one
of our prior presidents no that's not
who he is and thank God for that because
look at what he's getting done just a
final question just on Rhonda Santos and
the Florida government governor who you
said is doing crazy things at the moment
this week he introduced a ban on
abortion in Florida after six weeks do
you think Republican politicians will
not rest until abortion is effectively
outlawed in the U.S and what knock-on
effect does that have for 2024 well look
I think that seems to be the direction
that they are headed despite uh the
Supreme Court's decision when It
reversed uh Roe v Wade that this would
be left to the states we now see a lot
of efforts to Outlaw the so-called
medical abortion pills we see efforts to
try to limit when abortion would be
available even in cases of rape incest
in the life of the mother this is not
only a terrible policy that should be
rejected on its merits and what it does
to women and women's lives and women's
autonomy and women's rights
it is also a bad political decision we
have seen in every case where people
were given the chance to vote on whether
or not abortion should be uh continued
in their state or whether they vote for
someone to be on a court in Wisconsin
who is pro-abortion against someone who
is anti the anti-abortion forces have
lost so I am quite you know unbothered
by the political consequences but
extremely bothered by the real life
consequences of the fact that women will
die because they are not being given
appropriate reproductive health care
and we know that the people of Ireland
the Republic of Ireland overturned their
long-time ban on abortion because of the
consequences so it's only a matter of
time when that will also happen in the
United States but in the meantime there
will be damage but there will also be a
political advantage
two leaders who have a position that
recognizes that abortion is a part of
you know medical care for miscarriages
that it should be available in other
situations for women so I I think it's
going to hurt the Republican party but
I'm not I'm not advising them so you
know I just I worry about the I worry
about the real life consequences do you
think it will help them in 2024
absolutely absolutely I think that the
evidence so far is that people who have
tried to Outlaw abortion have lost and
you know it would be difficult in some
states because they're so controlled by
an anti-abortion government that they
won't be really able to do much yet but
in a national election it will be a real
problem for Republicans okay secretary
Clinton thank you so much for your time
thank you it's a pleasure to meet you
thank you